going into its final episode one world
one people the falcon and the winter
soldier had quite a bit to cover in a
relatively brief amount of time
a lot happened in the finale and it was
easy to overlook some key moments
here's the end of the falcon and the
winter soldier explained
one world one people kicks off right
where last week's episode truth wrapped
up with carly morgenthau
and the flag smashers executing their
plan to prevent the grc from voting on
the patch act bucky barnes and sharon
carter arrive on the scene to put a stop
to their scheme and not to be left out
sam wilson arrives at the party in grand
fashion
i'm sorry wait who are you captain
america i thought captain america was on
the moon
adorned with his brand new wakandan
armor and steve rogers iconic shield
sam bursts on the scene as the new
captain america after a fun skirmish
with patrack he uses his fresh set of
wings to take to the skies and rescue a
group of hostages aboard a flag
smasher's hijacked helicopter
sam's heroic display elicits cheers and
applause from the onlookers that have
gathered in the area
providing a stark contrast to the
shocked public reaction to john walker's
last public appearance
long time comics fans probably saw this
reveal coming 2014's captain america
number 25 saw sam officially take over
as the new captain america
when steve rogers stepped down what fans
probably didn't see coming was just how
comic book accurate the mcu version
would actually be
aside from a few small changes sam's new
captain america uniform is incredibly
faithful to the comic book version
at long last the falcon in the winter
soldier has revealed the identity of the
power broker though more than a few
viewers suspected it was sharon carter
all the while
indeed as one world one people reveals
sharon is apparently the unofficial
leader of
madrapore when batroc confronts sharon
during the climax of the fight with the
flagsmashers he threatens to reveal her
true identity unless she pays up
so she kills him without hesitation not
long after carly morgenthau manages to
hold sam who's lost his shield at
gunpoint
in response sharon put several bullets
into her back ending morgenthau's super
serum-fuelled destruction
not to mention permanently silencing yet
another person who knows her true
identity as the power broker
and exacting revenge on carly for
stealing the super soldier serum in the
first place
thanks to sharon's role in stopping the
flag smashers the united states
government grants her a full pardon
during the finale's post-credit scene
since no one not even sammer bucky knows
of sharon's villainous double life it's
only appropriate that no one bats an eye
when she gleefully accepts the
conditions of her return to the u.s
and her duty as an agent of the
government but when sharon leaves the
courthouse she speaks to someone on the
phone and what she says during the
conversation implies that she took the
deal only to buff up her business
prospects which will now
include top secret us weapons and
technology prototypes
even still some fans aren't convinced
that sharon carter really is the power
broker and they're not wrong to be
suspicious
scrolls the race of shape-shifting
aliens that were central to the plot of
2019's captain marvel are becoming a
bigger part of the mcu
after all the very last episode of
wandavision revealed a secret scroll
and we'll probably meet even more in the
upcoming secret invasion disney plus
series
with their leader gone things couldn't
get any worse for the flag smashers
right
wrong since the remaining members of the
group don't last much longer
once they're all rounded up and prepped
for a trip to the raft the prison where
baron zemo is currently being held their
armored escort goes up in a fiery
explosion
seemingly out of nowhere moments later
it comes to light that zema orchestrated
the flagsmasher's death from the comfort
of his prison cell
taking another step forward on his
mission of ridding the world of super
soldiers however as carly says earlier
in the episode the movement has gotten
big enough to survive
even their deaths and the fact that one
of the guards escorting the captured
flag smashers to prison reveals himself
to be a secret sympathizer
seems to prove her right even though all
the super-powered members of the flag
smashers are dead
the group could still return to the mcu
in a future project
what form that might take should it
actually happen of course is anybody's
guess
even without the us government's direct
endorsement sam wilson clearly becomes
captain america in the eyes of many over
the course of one world one people
however he's not afraid to criticize the
nation he represents
even though he wears the red white and
blue with pride this is made explicitly
clear when sam
verbally digs into the members of the
grc who still plan to move forward with
the patch act which would cause more
displacement and division across the
globe
in response to their decision sam gives
an impassioned speech as cameras
broadcast the confrontation to everyone
in the world
making it clear what he stands for he
disagrees with labels such as terrorists
for the flag smashers and spreading fear
and violence wasn't the core of their
mission they came into being as a result
of the failures of organized governments
filled with individuals who can't relate
to the struggles of the common person
as sam states moving forward with the
patch act would make the countries that
comprise the grc which includes the
united states
no better than the people these
government representatives label as
terrorists you control the banks
you can move borders you can knock down
a forest with the email you can feed a
million people
with a phone call to conclude his
statement
sam gives the policymakers something to
consider before they come to a final
verdict
after being held hostage and having
their lives endangered they've now
experienced the kind of fear and lack of
control that everyday people affected by
their policies feel so they should use
their power to help them
instead of making the wrong choice and
allowing more factions like the flag
smashers to rise and push for change
through violent means
in last week's truth john walker
completely loses his cool his fight
against bucky and sam as well as his
loss of the captain america mantle
leaves him a broken man
haunted by guilt over lamar's death and
armed with a makeshift shield
walker sets out to stop carly morgenthau
by any means necessary
though he doesn't end up killing
morgenthau he does help stop her and the
flag smashers from killing captured
members of the grc
further proving his usefulness to
contessa valentina allegra defontaine
aka
val don't call me that speaking of val
she reemerges near the end of one world
one people to give walker his new
costume and a new name
now that he's no longer the official
captain america walker is christened
u.s agent and dons a predominantly black
suit accented with red and white stripes
for those familiar with walker's history
in the pages of marvel comics this
change was a long time coming
walker's first comic book appearance as
us agent occurred in 1989's captain
america number 354.
the ending of the falcon in the winter
soldier episode 6 neatly ties up a
number of dangling threads bucky finally
figures out a way to productively find
closure for his time as the winter
soldier this is shown when he confronts
his elderly friend
yori nakajima and comes clean about
being the cause of his son's murder
he then sends his book of names back to
his therapist thanking her for all she's
done to help him
meanwhile sam pays a visit to isaiah
bradley and his grandson
elijah speaking with them about his
position as the first black captain
america
recognized by the public this leads sam
to take the two to the
smithsonian where a wing of the captain
america exhibit has been added to honor
isaiah for his service
and to ensure that the people know his
story one that was silenced for far too
long
to wrap up the episode sam returns home
with bucky to enjoy a well-deserved
cookout alongside his sister sarah and
the rest of the community
amid the chatter laughter and indulgence
the two avengers stand
side by side and acknowledge their
journey as the screen cuts to black the
text captain america and the winter
soldier appears
signifying a new era for sam wilson in
the mcu
in which he'll lead the charge not as
falcon but as captain america
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one